[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad en
senegal el día de la oposición es manson
como fue liberado por las autoridades
después de que sus seguidores
protagonizarán varios días de intensas
protestas que dejaron al menos cinco
muertos son co permanecerá bajo
vigilancia judicial por acusaciones de
violencia sexual de las cuales él se
declara inocente
al menos un centenar de fallecidos y más
de 600 heridos dejaron una serie de
explosiones en la ciudad ecuatoguineana
debata la capital económica del país un
incendio habría alcanzado el almacén de
explosivos dentro de un cuartel militar
y varios países africanos avanzan en sus
campañas de vacunación algunos con dos y
gestionadas por los gobiernos y otros
con las dominadas por el mecanismo
kóvacs liderado por organización mundial
para la salud
etiopía angola kenia nigeria senegal
ruanda y congo se encuentran en la lista
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días violentas
protestas sacudieron senegal después de
que el líder opositor guzmán songo fuera
detenido el pasado 3 de marzo por cargos
de desorden público de acusaciones de
violación son con fue liberado con
vigilancia judicial tras la presión de
sus seguidores pero el disturbio se
replicaron en la capital dakar ya que
los manifestantes acusan al presidente
actual macky sall de fabricar un complot
contra el líder de la oposición para
sacarlo del camino de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024
las protestas llevan días sacudiendo
senegal por la detención del líder
opositor ousman son co el político fue
liberado pero los disturbios se
recrudecieron con incendios y
lanzamiento de piedras son co alentó a
seguir las protestas aunque
pacíficamente
exigimos el pueblo senegalés ya la
juventud de particular que no se dan en
la movilización que no rompan esta
movilización excepcional
[Música]
las víctimas no deben ser en vano para
que eso no vuelva a suceder en senegal y
debemos mantener esta movilización debe
ser aún más grande pero debe ser
pacífica
fácil y el 3 de marzo son como un
activista crítico con el pasado colonial
francesa en general y la corrupción fue
detenido las autoridades lo acusaron de
violación a una chica cargos que niega
ya que cree que es un complot fabricado
por el oficialismo la liberación de
usman shonko es bajo control judicial
algo que la oposición considera injusto
el presidente llamó a la calma y
atribuyó los disturbios a la situación
desesperada de crisis y desempleo que
sufre el país
pido calma y paz todos juntos a callar
hemos nuestra propia amargura
aunque egipto y evitemos la lógica del
enfrentamiento que lleva a lo peor que
me and poor's aus manson co es el único
opositor activo en general y pretende
emprender una campaña para llegar al
poder en 2024 y asegurar que el actual
mandatario cumple su deber
constitucional y no se presenta a la
reelección
hablamos ahora de guinea ecuatorial'
porque una serie de explosiones
arrasaron con la ciudad de bata capital
económica del país hispanoparlante
causando daños masivos a la mayoría de
casas y establecimientos las explosiones
tuvieron lugar en una base militar donde
un incendio alcanzó una reserva de
municiones mal almacenadas la cifra de
muertos está alrededor del centenar
y destrucción en bata la capital
económica de guinea ecuatorial al menos
98 personas murieron y más de 600
resultaron heridas tras una serie de
explosiones en un cuartel del ejército
propio el presidente del país de oro
obiang emma aseguró que las explosiones
se debieron a negligencias relacionada
con el almacenamiento de dinamita
sobre los que iba a depositar las
dinámicas
en el depósito emisiones
[Música]
evidentemente tenemos que usar
un comunicado del ministerio de defensa
aclara que un incendio en un depósito de
armas provocó la explosión de municiones
de alto calibre con los hospitales
llenos de heridos el canciller simeón
angle pidió ayuda a la comunidad
internacional
ayuda
países amigos hermanos internacionales
[Aplausos]
los momentos son y más los esfuerzos de
rescate en bata continúan y el
ministerio de salud del país advirtió
que muchos residentes aún podrían estar
atrapados bajo los escombros y ahora se
está investigando la causa exacta del
incendio que provocó la explosión pero
el presidente obiang nguema dijo que
podría deberse a que los agricultores
locales prendieron fuego a los campos
que rodean el cuartel hablamos ahora de
alcoy 19 porque alrededor de 4 millones
de dosis de la vacuna contra el virus
llegaron a la capital de nigeria abuya
por medio de la iniciativa kóvacs varios
otros países del continente han recibido
lotes del medicamento entre ellos
etiopía que recibió 2,2 millones de
dosis
recientemente cargamentos de vacunas
entregadas por el mecanismo liderado por
la organización mundial de la salud
llegaron a luanda la capital de angola y
a nairobi la capital de kenia donde ya
avanzan las jornadas de vacunación
también en kigali la capital de ruanda
más de 800.000 dosis fueron recibidas
por autoridades sanitarias por su parte
senegal recibió más de 300 mil dosis
están bien donadas por
para la inmunización de la población
prioritaria la iniciativa kóvacs comenzó
su despliegue en el continente africano
y está ampliando sus entregas en varios
países
el programa está respaldado por la
organización mundial de la salud y su
objetivo es proporcionar vacunas para
países pobres e ingresos medios
nosotros esperamos en realizar entregas
a angola demos ya la república
democrática del congo y nigeria
edwin now desde ahora y hasta finales de
mayo se entregarán 237 millones de dosis
de vacunas en 142 países que participan
en kóvacs y 65 gas recientemente
llegaron casi 4 millones de dosis de la
vacuna contra el jove 19 a la capital de
nigeria abuya la poliomielitis y nigeria
después de una campaña que duró años no
hubiéramos podido hacerlo si una vacuna
esta es una herramienta esencial de la
medicina de los lotes fueron producidos
por el instituto serum de la india estas
son las primeras de 16 millones de dosis
que kóvacs planea entregar en los
próximos meses al país cuya población
supera los 200 millones de personas
es muy importante que los que trabajan
en el sector de la salud se vacunen
primero para que sigan la campaña contra
el cubit 19 pero también para otras
campañas de inmunización nutrición
infantil
aquí es donde sentiremos el impacto
el gobierno nigeriano instó a los
gobernantes tradicionales líderes
religiosos grupos de la sociedad civil y
a los medios de comunicación a difundir
el mensaje de los esenciales que son las
vacunas en la lucha contra la pandemia
del coronavirus marruecos del primer
productor de cannabis a nivel mundial
con éxito de la nación norteafricana a
trabajar en un proyecto de ley para
promover los usos medicinales del
cannabis desde marrakech nos amplía
nuestra corresponsal sofía catalán el
gobierno de marruecos prepara un
proyecto de ley para la despenalización
del uso terapéutico del cannabis este
país es el mayor productor de cannabis
del mundo y el debate sobre la
despenalización tiene una larga
trayectoria esta planta se cultiva desde
hace siglos de forma ilegal en las
montañas del rif una de las regiones más
empobrecidas del país allí habría más de
50 mil áreas de cultivo y más de 100.000
personas
exclusivamente de las plantaciones y
según el estudio del proyecto leyes en
legalizar la industria cannábica podría
repercutir muy positivamente la economía
del país por lo que la mayoría de
formaciones políticas se muestran a
favor a excepción eso sí del partido de
la justicia y el desarrollo único
partido islamista legal en marruecos y
que ostenta ahora mismo en la
presidencia del gobierno no obstante
estos islamistas no tienen mayoría
parlamentaria ni los ministerios más
relevantes como es el caso del interior
artífice de este proyecto leyes de
llegar al parlamento por tanto podría
ser aprobado con facilidad y por otra
parte en la legalización del uso
terapéutico del cannabis tiene buena
aceptación social pero los agricultores
del reef lamentan que no se haya contado
con ellos para elaborar el proyecto ley
además de ser el primer productor de
cannabis marruecos es el país más
turístico del continente africano y a
pesar de haber sido el primero en
iniciar su campaña de vacunación el
sector turístico sigue fuertemente
golpeado a causa del virus
en las montañas del atlas de marruecos
los guías a caballo están actualmente
desempleados hace meses que los turistas
extranjeros han dejado de venir aquí a
causa de la pandemia los propietarios de
hoteles dicen que han perdido más de dos
tercios de sus clientes
después y bill ward esperamos que los
turistas extranjeros regresen al país
porque realmente salvarían la situación
la situación se cancelaron las
vacaciones grupales y los seminarios
este museo abrió el año pasado pero
permanece vacío los vendedores de
recuerdos no tienen nada que hacer
ver la que es él
las ventas son bajas los turistas que
antes compraban cosas ya no vienen
ahora solo vemos gente que viene y toma
fotos
pero la falta de turistas beneficia a
los monos de la región
durante el encierro los monos y otros
animales que viven aquí ya no fueron
alimentados por los turistas por lo que
regresaron a sus fuentes naturales de
alimento antes de la pandemia los
turistas extranjeros solían dar
comunidad
a estos monos atlas que son una especie
en peligro de extinción están comiendo
de manera más saludable
se conmemoró el día internacional de la
mujer y por eso en áfrica siete días
resaltamos la historia de una ingeniera
ingenia que si una máquina para
convertir desechos plásticos en
ladrillos de construcción con su empresa
espera contribuir al medio ambiente y al
emprendimiento de otras mujeres
africanas
la ingeniera sunbeam a ti es la
fundadora de yeniet makers una empresa
con sede en nairobi que convierte los
desechos plásticos en ladrillos para
construcción asegura que el material es
muy resistente y no se rompe ni agrieta
hasta con nuestro producto es casi de 5
a 7 veces más resistente que el hormigón
y su fábrica produce en 1500 ladrillos
por día tras reciclar polietileno de
alta densidad polietileno de baja
densidad y residuos plásticos a base de
polipropileno sin embargo no procesa
plástico pet luego venden los ladrillos
por metros cuadrados uy sabíamos hacer
un ladrillo así que necesitábamos saber
si vamos a llevar este producto al
mercado necesitábamos saber cómo hacer
mil o cinco mil porque un proyecto no
puede ser sólo un ladrillo entonces
después de descubrir cómo hacer un
ladrillo ahora el siguiente paso fue
cómo hacer miles
necesitábamos máquinas gracias a sus
estudios de ingeniería matti diseñó sus
propias máquinas ella asegura que su
fábrica ha reciclado 20 toneladas de
plástico desde 2017 el ministerio de
medio ambiente y sí
cultura dice que kenia produce 600 mil
toneladas de botellas de plástico al año
de las cuales 400.000 se utilizan
localmente y sólo el 9% se recicla
y finalizamos también con música a
propósito del día internacional de la
mujer desde venir la starter meaning
band presenta su nuevo sencillo titulado
south african de la star femenino band
está conformada por siete chicas entre
los 10 y los 17 años todas originarias
de nati team a un remoto poblado en zona
rural desde donde cantan al rol
fundamental de la mujer en la sociedad
africana así finalizamos en áfrica siete
días ustedes pueden continuar con más en
france 24 puntos con nos vemos más
adelante
[Música]
ah